after 18 months of talks in nearly two
decades of war the US and the Afghan
Taliban have just signed a longer way to
deal
aimed at paving the way to peace and the
departure of foreign troops now the
leader of the Taliban delegation mullah
Abdul Ghani Barada and the u.s. envoi
for peace in Afghanistan's al mahalla
lozad signed the agreement in Doha
watched by dignitaries including the US
Secretary of State and foreign ministers
from Qatar and Pakistan under the deal
the US and NATO said they'll pull out
all foreign troops within 14 months if
the Taliban honors its part of the
agreement and that includes a 135 day
initial period to reduce violence both
sides have also agreed to exchange as
many as up to 6,000 prisoners now the US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says the
agreement is a crucial first step
towards peace this agreement will mean
nothing and today's good feelings will
not last if we don't take concrete
actions on commitments and promises that
have been made when it comes down to it
the future of Afghanistan is for Afghans
to determine the u.s. Taliban deal
creates the conditions for Afghans to do
just that here's our tank here's our
take on what steps by the Taliban will
make this agreement a success first keep
your promises to cut ties with al Qaeda
and other terrorists keep up the fight
to defeat Isis Osama bin joins our
correspondent following events for us
from that signing of the deal in Doha a
long time in coming it was on and off
for well many times over the 18 months
Osama there must be a sign of relief
from diplomats there absolutely as you
heard the US Secretary of State saying
that the United States will not fight in
perpetuity in the graveyard of Empires
that is how the United States saw its
presence in Afghanistan that is
something that the Afghan Taliban wanted
to end and it looks like that is what
has been achieved in Doha after months
of wrangling and negotiations this is
the process which started ten years ago
when mullah Mohammad Omar was
in charge of the Taliban but now finally
after the office of the Taliban is open
in 2003 2013 rather in Doha they have
inked this agreement according to this
agreement all sides will have to abide
by their respective terms the United
States will gradually withdraw its
troops you see the 7-day reduction in
violence expanded to 135 days and then a
graduate of withdrawal within 14 months
of all American and foreign troops they
will be initially leaving five bases as
well the Afghan government is going to
push the United Nations to remove
members of the Taliban from the
sanctions list the Afghan Taliban is
going to not just reduce violence but it
is going to continue its fight against
ISIL and make sure that its soil is
never used again by al Qaeda
so there's a lot at stake but again a
first step towards lasting peace in
Afghanistan has been taken you heard
from the Qatari foreign minister as well
that the state of Qatar has played an
important role at a time when people had
forgotten that there is still a chance
for peace in Afghanistan and it took up
the mantle and has been facilitating
that process you also heard from the
Pakistani Foreign Minister earlier
saying that Pakistan remains committed
welcomes a prosperous and peaceful
Afghanistan for its neighbors as well
and on that note of whether Pakistan's
dealings with the Taliban are going to
be monitored by the United States he
told us that Pakistan has nothing to
hide and Pakistan will be making sure
that all its dealings are in the open so
it is a historic and momentous occasion
but like you said the proof is going to
be in the pudding that in the coming
days and months are going to decide
where the peace in Afghanistan is going
to move from a signed document to
reality on the ground there are many you
might say roadblocks in the way as well
as are makers for example we have a
fractious government in Kabul at the
moment they've just gone through a
presidential election this all can't
decide on who will be the president as
such then we have obviously groups like
ISIL and al Qaeda still operating in
Afghanistan the bigger questions will be
how this agreement works in how the US
and Taliban work together to defeat
these militant groups or
terror groups as they're often described
and how they can manage to bring the
government to the negotiating table and
now and get the the government in Kabul
and the Taliban to talk to each other
many hurdles absolutely soon to quote
the defense secretary of the United
States who said there are known knowns
and unknown unknowns and this is where
we're at yes it is a momentous occasion
yes it is historic that they have signed
this agreement but again the Islamic
Emirate of Afghanistan is the name by
which the Taliban calls itself and they
still want to use that name that has
been a sticking point they don't
recognize the Afghan government as a
legitimate government and say that it's
been propped up by occupying forces they
see this as a victorious occasion where
they say this is the Nagri Minh to end
the occupation of Afghanistan how are is
there 5,000 release a number of
prisoners 5,000 on the Taliban side and
a thousand soldiers that are being held
by the Taliban are going to be released
what are going to be the modalities of
sharing power remember this is not in
Afghanistan which was in 2001 it is 2020
awareness on has moved on and that is
something that many analysts are going
to be watching how these these
situations take place on the ground the
Taliban says that it still controls 70%
of territory on the ground I asked the
Taliban delegation that it is often said
that the government holds the ethos the
day and the Taliban holds the night and
he laughed and said that was in the past
Taliban holds the day and the night in
Afghanistan Osama of course we'll get
more analysis from you as the day
progresses let's cross over to the US
now our correspondent Alan Fisher is
standing by in Washington DC this is a
huge foreign policy success for
President Trump he is obviously going to
run with this in what is an important
year for him big tick in the box and he
needed a foreign policy success you
remember that he essentially put all his
eggs in the North Korean basket in the
first two years how the two leaders
there had written wonderful letters to
one another Donald Trump saying that
they fell in love here he's promised
that he will start to withdraw American
troops and and that certainly seen
to be the Gaul here at the moment
there's around twelve thousand there
Donald Trump has been speaking for years
about taking troops out of Afghanistan
he believes that while it was right to
go into Afghanistan that they have been
there too long and that is certainly a
view shared by many Americans and not
just Trump supporters
if these interlocking agreements as Mike
Pompeo describes them works then the
United States will start withdrawing
troops within the next hundred days or
so down from 12,000 to about 8,000 600
and that number will continue to
decrease now put that in perspective
during the surges that we saw in
Afghanistan when the United States was
seeking a military victory there was
about 120,000 US military personnel in
the country so down significantly in
that period there has been criticism of
this agreement there are Republicans who
are worried they believe that the
Taliban have made promises in the past
and simply not delivered I think Mike
Pompeo was speaking directly to them in
his news conference in Doha just in the
last 20 minutes or so when he said we
know exactly who we are dealing with so
finally this administration seems to
have got a deal over the line you'll
remember that back in September there
was the possibility that the Taliban was
going to go to Camp David the
presidential retreat in Maryland that
was around the weekend of the 9/11
anniversary many people thought that was
incredibly bad timing torn deaf by the
Trump administration that perhaps played
a part and the rule in Donald Trump
suddenly canceling the talks although
there was the death of an American
soldier in the country at that time and
he said that the deal could be done he
might never do a deal with the Taliban
but we know behind the scenes in Doha
with the State Department with the envoi
of those discussions continued and that
took us to the point where we are today
for the motel and thank you of course I
will come back to you for more reaction
from the u.s. in Afghanistan of course
President Ashraf Ghani welcomed the
possible end of the war but also
cautioned that discussions between the
Taliban and his government what ongoing
our agenda for
discussion with the Taliban will be
wider than their discussions with the
United States they should be ready to
discuss their relationship whether the
state and non-state sponsors a
verifiable system for cutting off their
ties with all transnational terrorist
groups their dependents an involvement
with narcotics and other transnational
criminal organizations positively Bob
Bashara is our senior political analyst
here at al-jazeera Mar will be speaking
for the last couple of hours about
what's just gone on here in Doha yet in
Afghanistan words of caution real angst
amongst the public because at the end of
the day it's their lives that have been
in turmoil right at the grassroots at
the coalface so to speak for the last
four decades and they haven't got the
institutions they haven't got the real
politicians that they can have belief in
that can move this forward so it's is it
no wonder that everybody's asking will
this work it's it's the first step in a
thousand-mile was it were you know it's
very similar to Iraq but lacks a lot of
the institution that here Iraq had had
for long and Afghanistan has been going
through this for now for 40 years since
the Soviet invasion in 1979 until today
Afghanistan has been in a state of war
now regardless how you point a finger at
whom whether it is Washington's fault or
goddess fault
Moscow's fault Pakistan's fall Taliban
or whoever
Afghanistan has suffered for 40 years
what and while Matt Pompeo speaks of
nine thousand nine million students
going school in Afghanistan and that is
a good thing comparison to 2001 but 2001
was also after two decades of war so yes
there are some tangible achievements
within Kabul and within the centers of
population but the rest of Afghanistan
is divided among warlords and the
Taliban today so it's very hard to see
how this country is going to be able to
put together first of all it needs
healing
reconciliation then it needs to be
building
building not just State Building it's
actually now at this point in time
probably needs some nation-building as
well because the the the national fabric
has been torn apart so much for the last
40 years that to bring back trust among
say the Taliban and the Kabul government
it's gonna take along a long while and
between some of the liberal open-minded
elites or not so much elites just women
and men in Kabul who want full equality
who want social justice and the Taliban
that is insisting on some radical
phonetic interpretation of Islam that's
gonna take time so on all levels on the
social and religious on the economic on
the nation building on the state
building there's gonna be a lot of work
so just focus on one aspect of that and
at the moment we have a government in
Kabul you might say in crisis we have
the president and the CEO not speaking
to each other after and yet another
election and nobody really understanding
who's going to lead the negotiations if
they ever do get to the table with the
Taliban because that's what the US and
other stakeholders would like to see as
the next move within this next 135 days
my sense is that today's ceremony in
Kabul and I could be wrong that the
United States is interested to make sure
Ashraf Ghani remains the at the
forefront of this endeavor if you were
and his release of his own peace plan
back in October underlines this idea
that he's in sync with Washington over
what's next for Afghanistan because
while this thing is going to be going on
the unit's it's is going to remain
involve the next 14 months and I think
the United States will have a say over
who's who in Kabul and who will be
sitting with the Taliban because they
made that contingent over their
withdrawal from Afghanistan but really
it's going to be important for Afghan is
now to step up because the United States
for all practical purpose whether it's
the public or Washington they have
checked out in fact they probably have
concluded some 10 years ago after the
killing of Osama bin Laden that it was
time for them to leave and why haven't
they left
left well it's politics and the usual
Pride and Prejudice right but now
leaving they are and hence in Kabul as
well as the Taliban they need to pick up
the pieces come together because there's
going to be no one else other than them
that will be able to take Afghanistan to
the next step towards some sort of
national reconciliation who should see
what happens the rabbit Mohan thank you